what was it like joining the team
obviously it was new for you this season
in the boss the everyone's quite
friending the same site you get along on
the set what's like kind of joining this
close-knit group now it wasn't at all
really like everyone was I was eased
into it he was ostracized for a while
yeah yeah yeah they had me doing all
sorts and I mean I still and kind of
taking me under his wing a bit and I'm
still working on the rest of him no it
was I was kind of eased into it I sort
of did a little bit of filming move I
think Chloe first and then like Clark
and then gradually everyone kind of
everyone's at Comic Con my first we came
it was kind of a nuts nuts first day
because I was shooting here in London on
the Thursday wrapped on that went to bed
got up in the morning got on a plane
flew to LA got picked up taking certain
was into costume and makeup and I was
like I said tomorrow I'm Sookie can I
just like get a shot you know just got
off the flight I was like just grab a
shower and just freshen up and they were
like well we kind of need you and I was
just straight onto set like to start
shooting so no but was very very
fortunate that everyone's so kind of
chilled and fun friendly and everything
yeah with the Martha move all up sorry
with the Marvel movie franchises being
such these huge critical and commercial
successes do you guys feel like an added
pressure to really knock it out of the
park with the TV show I think you're
kind of getting a little bubble don't
you when you're shooting it you kind of
not forget your mother no I do like you
just sort of forget about the rest of it
because things happen so quickly like
it's really fast pace we're getting
scripts you know almost every week and
you know there's so much to shoot we
shoot an episode in eight days so
there's no real time to kind of worry
about the rest of it it's there yeah you
know it's only when you do stuff like
this that you realize that people watch
it oh yeah that people actually see what
we're doing it what do you see that
actually because was talks about you
having a possible spinoff hmm
obviously that hasn't went foraging or
why or what happened with that um I
think it's one of those those Marvel
things where there's kind of you know
rumors get put out there and I don't
think anything was ever kind of bolted
on for it but I don't know where the
idea is completely gone away or or what
at the moment so it's kind of you know
who knows you know what Marvel are like
yeah yeah yeah
yeah it basically the series got ditched
because we got the movie franchise
coming I'm going to give me the dead
weight like Bobby come back on Chicago
he's working he's and think everyone I
think most people were big fans of what
stuff he's done before so see some
wonder that come in and really care
about it stuff really commit to like a
great crazy character like that was
really cool experience for me and I yeah
he's really fun I didn't like the read
trees and stuff always enjoy it when
when he's there in terms of the second
season it's been kind of more
action-packed in terms of fast paced and
it's been very kind of in-your-face in
comparison to the first one we had more
sort of slow pace and build how'd you
guys find kind of adjusting to that
because it's it must be like a lot of
pressure kind of getting into that
getting to these rather intense stories
that leads up to like movie such as age
of Ultron versus theirs to I mean I
think in terms of season I think in
season two I think specifically like
kind of the end of season one I think we
sure really start to begin to find his
feet I think of the star it was kind of
there was so much happening in things
that it was all a bit crazy and and then
I think now in season two it kind of
found its voice a lot more I think ball
so at the same time we we find out week
to week what's happening as well so it's
kind of we choose like we tune in every
week to get script and you know we're
kind of excited to see what happens so
you don't tend to think too far ahead
really which is which is a good and bad
thing I think there's been some new
additions to the cast that pretty
elevated it as well as yeah there's
Adrian Henry there's been a few people I
mean obviously there's a great chemistry
between the whole cast but you know I
mean particularly between you and
Natasha
think Fitzsimmons is such a beautiful
pairing can you talk a little bit about
protecting that relationship she'll kill
me we don't tell you my name's Elizabeth
she's the best I mean everyone's best
friend she's kind of she's no she's cool
and that a lot of that you know to be
honest is probably within the writing
and stuff that's kind of been a kind of
early thing that which they always did
that kind of relationship between the
two of them and and it's nice because
they're seasoned they've taken in quite
a few different directions which has
been cool so it's actually changed a lot
and they've both grown up a lot of
things separately which has been good I
think it's really an awesome for the
fans because it's kind of you've got a
lot of those kind of the love a lot of
the kind of a superhero world it's like
very heroic characters and people with
superpowers that kind of dominate those
love stories and then it's really nice
having one more it's like these are the
scientists guys you kind of do the jobs
that you know people can relate to and
stuff yeah in that kind of world
well anyway I think Elizabeth's
character Simmons definitely wears the
trousers in their relationship fest is
definitely much more of a girl than
input you getting to the scripts in your
practice I mean the I mean definitely I
think they're kind of right for the
actors as well like you know you realize
I've definitely felt that after the
first few episodes you can start to kind
of see how they're they're taking things
that they've seen you do on set and kind
of using that and expanding it and so on
and I mean I've not had you know this is
gonna be my next my second season that
we're coming up to and there's
conversations and that you have with the
show runners and so on so I've kind of
not gone through that but obviously ian
has an
thinking that's an opportunity to get
some input as well yeah it was quite a
departure for your character in terms of
what sort of well did you do any sort of
research for the character yeah we did
yeah
I mean first off it was the writers and
stuff with the showrunners did a lot of
research into that kind of stuff and
they kind of told me their idea for the
thing and then I can wind in my own so
it was a yeah it was a collaboration in
that sense but well I think we were
always just very aware that that is
something very real thing that's
happened to a lot of people in a very
real way so we just wanted to kind of
make sure we were respectful to it
because there's a certain responsibility
I think involved with it you just kind
of yeah that you sure that you do
respectfully so yeah but actually a lot
the work was done for me by the way yeah
obviously
Captain America Winter Soldier had huge
knock-on effects for your show do you
guys ever hear kind of rumblings in
advance of like something's gonna happen
and start to wonder whether or not your
characters gonna be dramatically changed
in forthcoming episodes well no we don't
hear too much I mean let them be there
was that thing like Clarke will often
come up and like be like oh I'm really
sorry about you know what's happened to
my thing you'd be like what what's
happening and he'll just be one yup so
like you do kind of hear you do kind of
hear rumblings of stuff but like things
have it's something but like with
Captain America I think they showed us a
screening I can unfinished version of
the film just so we kind of knew the
story because we were starting to film
episodes which relate to it just so we
kind of knew what was going on so with
something really big like that they
usually tell you yeah yeah but they're
very they keep it very tight but they
wouldn't let you you know they make sure
you know what you need to know it's on a
need-to-know basis yeah
I'd like I'd like hunter to get a
disability that means he's in a
wheelchair so I just get to sit down it
was you know apart from I suppose that
as just doing it definitely there's the
money like pluses Britain turmeric I
really thought to be credible about in
terms of what I do it's that kind of
it's the exact same thing I mean you you
learn your lines in your book on your
character you go on and you try and do
the best you can really and when you're
in front of the camera that that for me
doesn't change but yeah the background I
suppose does change it's just more food
on set what you think it is look you
know what it is I think I think I like
an international feel to it and
obviously we've got the advantage that
we share the same language I think I
know that's definitely something in in
our show that they're conscious of that
gives them when I only auditioned for
the part it wasn't specific whether he
was American aware is from they were
open to it and they were at one point I
think there was talk that you know he
was going to be American and then they
said no no we want you to use your own
accent so I think up until you know
probably a couple of weeks before
filming it was still up in the air
though I was gonna be playing him
American or not because originally I
don't think he was gonna be Lance hunter
necessarily he was you know because
obviously has got a history in the comic
book world but you know I don't know
really I mean I think I think there's
this some I thought however the
Americans just think the British a bit
more refined and a bit more kind of like
you know cultured in their the optical
arts so I'm quite happy for them to
believe that
referenced the other way around because
well there's some very much mistaken
when Nick Fury cuts his way out of the
bottom of the car in Winter Soldier
that's an invention that on the show was
a sacrifice invented when omen watched
the latest Avengers film there's that
massive ship thing I was just did you
guys ever have any ambitions to do a
show like this I mean obviously the
Marvel kind of universe has been growing
and growing and growing all the way
since Iron Man do you think though years
ago that I got I could end up on really
thanks ed a really good thing to me
recently where he was like well well we
were just talking about you know the you
can quite often when you're doing any
sort of job like we all know it's like
you get kind of lost in there and you
forget that moment when you first got it
in you're really excited and all this
stuff and you get used to it you you and
you know you kind of have to guard
against taking it for granted and we
were talking about it just saying you
know if you could if your ten-year-old
self could see you and you're in this
big Marvel series and so on you're just
the excitement of that that kid would
have you know and you just remind
yourself of that and yeah I feel very
fortunate
anything like like basically for those
who want to get into I mean acting in
thank you so I've just got that first
step what how hard is it like from that
step from to move into Marvel basically
because Marvel is a really big deal yeah
well I think what I would say is is
don't make a specific thing your aim
like something like you know say no I
want to be in a Marvel thing it's that I
think that you need to fall in love with
acting before you think about the jobs
that you might get or the scale of them
and so on and I just say you've got to
be really determined you've got to work
hard be nice to people
and and also I think find happiness
outside of it
I think that quite often you know a lot
of people I know I'm sure you know lots
of people that their whole aim is is to
be a success of acting and we know that
we've been fortunate with the right
things coming up at the right time you
know and some people don't have that
fortune and you've got a fine
satisfaction outside of it it's quite
serious Hans thank you solve the world
of that I was gonna cry I think as well
like saying something
sounds like a contrived but I think from
Eno the biggest thing is just working
hard like making sure you can like at
the end of every day just scored like
did I do everything the kids like to
work on that thing I think no escape I
almost gave out his phone number we're
doing a live on the air charity thing
and I said oh yeah we said a raise a
certain amount of money I'll just give
it my phone number and I think I gave
out like seven digits or something of it
and he goes have to believe he cuz I'm
just going to the toilet and sudden I
get this call from this person being
like oh hi it wasn't it was neck I mean
talking about having fun I mean
obviously your characters get to play
with an invent some pretty fun tech I'm
curious what are the best toys you've
got to play with um I'd like to mean
they gave me a football the drones were
always pretty cool I haven't used them
in a while actually
the strange thing is is but there was
when you're doing it like you'll have
ones there but then they'll CGI them out
so a lot of the time you'll just be but
you can do what you want and look around
and they'll see Jeremy's really windup
the CGI guys yeah or you can do the ones
where um you got like a hologram table
and basically you just do this for 10
minutes yeah a lot of gadgets aren't
actually there so you know it's just
like after see anything on eyes they
actually do bring a lot of the men that
have little lights or beeps or whatever
things that lay up I mean they're
basically just lights to slow boxes the
place what you guys think in terms of
like the difference between the Marvel
movies and the
TV shows for instance where'd you think
the difference is lying in them because
I find like the story instructor on the
TV show it's got a lot more time to kind
of develop character yes whereas in the
films it's kind of banging your faces I
think that the films you tend to go to a
cinema for the TV you just kind of easy
remote I think yeah I mean there's
obviously a thing with the scale of it I
think there's one but you're right I
think I think something like daredevil
was a really good example of how a team
how something like a TV series can be
more involving than a film because they
stretched at that she'll backstories in
a very cool way I thought yeah but it's
actually quite you know this story over
the actual story catch the CUDA blasted
the length of a movie but with all the
backstories and everything they just
they stretched it out and made it much
much more like a book or something I
think yeah I think there's an audience
member so you can just get to know the
characters a lot better and I think
people connect with them because you
know me they're everywhere they're every
week spending an hour or two with them
what are the cool sides of it as well I
was like you know it's like you know you
get people would go back comic every we
can catch up on I suppose is that side
too as well yeah I think obviously in
the comic book world there's a pretty
fierce rivalry between Marvel and DC and
particularly the big screen Marvel has
been crushing it you guys aware of that
rivalry and how do you feel about that I
mean I've got friend is in DC things
know maybe like the the business guys
have more of a rivalry now it's not
something they know unduly talks about
so you don't mean that
I think though across to Marvel and DC
in the last couple of years it's fair to
say we've seen kind of an explosion in
the pocket I already superheroes comic
books again that we might have seen
before I was born
let me talk to be really cliche do you
think it's no cooler to be involved with
a superhero franchise that it was thing
like 10 years ago we got like writing
silly Matthew McConaughey or looking at
talking about being in that like series
for like Marvel and DC do you think
there's been some sort of shift push it
back to being popular again I think
those stories can um they can be told in
a very different way than they could 20
years ago with the advancements of
technology and stuff like that probably
as a big so yeah when you look at like
the original Batman series and then
running around in tights and they're
pretty scrawny underneath everything in
this power and back I mean I kind of
love backs yeah you know the start of it
was so cool but um I think he's an actor
you'd probably feel pretty silly you
know in in a kind of spray-on thing
without any all that padding and all
this amazing costume and stuff and yeah
you know pretending stuff's there there
is and and fighting cardboard monsters
or whatever but now it just looks and
credit I mean like some of the stuff in
the Avengers film was insane and we're
amazed every week that well they manage
still on the show I mean I when I got
there my first day and I was like that
was when I first realized that this it
was an episode every eight days and I
was like you're shooting I mean was is
so it's 40 odd minutes showing some film
you know see you're shooting half a
movie in eight days I mean if I was
moving exact I'd be going uh why are we
taking nine months to shoot this yeah
yeah I think that's a major part of it I
think you're able to make them look look
cool and and also the popularity you
know so many people are watching them so
as an actor people you know that's part
of you know the decision making process
against you know I'm talking about
actors obviously you mentioned Elizabeth
earlier on but I'm curious you talked a
little bit about the rest of the cast
because it's a really great mix and
ensemble yeah we're really lucky like
Clark
is a you know in some ways I think
people's characters like mirror
themselves officer yeah I think Clark is
definitely the leader of our group and
he sets the tone and I suppose the only
person that's very different
the character is Ming she's absolutely
insane she's like a child is that too
many Smarties yeah too many sui's every
morning I like six cans of Diet Coke
cause she gets her a bit I think that's
what she does her Red Bull yeah yeah
she's not in Red Bull but she's in the
best way you give an example to
elaborate on how much she is I mean in
what way she knows what did she do she
just she'll dance she doesn't stop that
she dances more than she doesn't dance
yeah yeah yes she loves her innuendos he
loves her in those and she laughs more
than she doesn't laugh yeah during the
day it's hard to get through scene with
her baby
luckily I'm not in that many scenes with
her no the moment no undeceive I really
enjoyed when I did my stuff with Adrian
when I got kidnapped and I got yanked on
the back of a car and dumped in the
field and then in a helicopter and I
wasn't actually meant to we shot the
scenes where the scene where we're
talking in the helicopter just on the
ground you know there anything you can
see how the windows is obviously CGI but
they had to get the shot the helicopter
taking off and going through the
mountains and um there was no intention
for us to be in there for it they were
just gonna do that fellas are getting in
that helicopter and it was amazing it
was one it's really fun working Vedran
he's he's he's so on it and really funny
and a really nice guy but also bombing
through the guy who did the helicopter
stuff to the guy does Michael Bay's
stuff so he's incredibly he's like the
top guy and we were just going through
the mountains in a that we're near the
biz near entre it's at Anaheim I didn't
know about this anyway like you know
bombing through and when you're doing
that and it was incredible if so you I
don't think they'd even announce that I
was in a show at that point so I
couldn't anyone I had this video I'm my
phone just itching to show yeah that was
that was a lot of fun yeah
I really like the relationship in the
show as well we're talking about other
actors and I really like also the
relationship between Fitz and Mack and I
was wondering what if you talk about it
because it was one of the first to
actually speak to fit like properly and
stop bidding him like it was he had a
problem of something and I really like
how you brought it forward in the show
and it was a really interesting thing
and then second second half of season so
everything goes to hell and then
suddenly they're not friends anymore
so I was wondering how I was to work
with that angry and how you approach
that relationship as well Emily's great
he's just he's a nice man he's a big
gentle giant like and he was great
coming in as well like and and yeah this
I think it's just exactly what you said
in terms of the characters everyone else
knew FETs before as injury so treated
him very differently which was the last
thing you wanted was you know Mack took
him for face value didn't know we didn't
know many different that was the person
he knew and I think he appreciated that
kind of mollycoddle women anything I
think is a good example of the way the
writers writing for the lack
collaboration as well because you know
they've obviously seen in Henry himself
he's got that completely open mind in
this doesn't even kind of accepting of
anyone one and I think that was probably
an influence on that relationship yeah
yeah it's true and yeah I mean has has
biceps are bigger than my head I'm like
they look like fake boobs they're so big
if they weren't so rock-hard it need a
broth room because they're massive baby
he can move them to like a song like
he's we went out for dinner just before
we came back to the UK and I did sort of
think it must look really weird this
like six foot six dude is absolutely
massive and I was too kind of like out
to dinner with his kids we always laugh
because there's one thing he says like
if you have you say something that's
like and he's surprising but he'll be
like you just look a Wingo actually said
the other day is really when I did you
realize real people said that I'm a bit
just in comics
you